this year marks the 150th anniversary of
the first ascent of the Matterhorn for
150 years Mountaineers have been
reaching the summit of the iconic Swiss
mountain but more than 500 people have
lost their lives there
twice as many as on Mount Everest dr.
Marten vaulter is on call around the
clock to rescue climbers in trouble it's
dangerous work and demands everything
from him and his team will they manage
to get where they're needed in time this
weekend
it's 4:00 in the morning on the only
Ridge 15 climbers are on their way to
the summit
three thousand meters lower the air tear
Mott rescue team members begin their
working day German dr. Martin Weiser has
been part of the team for 15 years
always one week at a time he's on call
for 24 hours a day his morning starts
with a routine check ampules for
injections bandages and dressings for
injuries everything has to be in its
place when an emergency hits because to
house photo challenge is that as an
emergency doctor I first have to
recognize what's going on very rapidly
assess the situation quickly and know
what to do hunting when it's wide mean
secondly a challenge that's just as big
or even bigger in the mountains is to be
sure to communicate with my team and
never go anywhere putting myself and my
patient at risk a call comes in the
dispatcher receives a report of a
stranded hiker she immediately sends out
Susy excuse me but what's your numbers
of orders who's he petitioner Susy is
one of four helicopters at the base
a hiker at the foot of the Matterhorn
has to be evacuated he climbed 3,000
meters wearing only sneakers rather than
proper boots now he's stuck in the snow
and rocks
vaulters team includes a paramedic and
mountain specialist to ensure the safety
of the doctor and his patients anyone
who's been flying here for years and
most of them have been here for many
years is so experienced they can usually
deal with any medical situation they
have to because we're much more occupied
with assessing the situation to see if
everything's safe and the patient is
secure and making sure we're not putting
ourselves in danger
pilot Donnie often blurtin heads for a
Ledge vault sir we'll wait there with
the equipment that way the helicopter
can remain light and maneuverable
ilex dislike there's no time for fear
sometimes afterwards you really have to
say wow we were really lucky back there
that can happen of course you just have
to approach each rescue mission with a
certain amount of deliberation
the rescue specialist is winched down
from the helicopter
it's a 150-meter drop the pilot has to
keep the copter steady so the rescuer
doesn't get flung against the mountain
after a few minutes the rescuer is
pulled on board again with the hiker
hitched onto him physically the hiker is
okay after Martine violets er gets back
on board as well they return to base
that's again you have to be ox diagon
the Mountaineers and patients never get
on my nerves they're part of our job if
people climb a mountain without the
proper equipment they'll create a
situation that could also put rescuers
at risk as well but that doesn't really
bother me this is what I've decided to
do
the hiker will have to pay for the
rescue himself the rescue specialist
appeals to his conscience going climbing
in jeans and sneakers can be fatal
the hiker admits he made a poor decision
the rescuer asks again for his ID and
writes down his details just to be sure
back in the office
Valter catches up on his reports he
writes up the times and details of three
separate operations skip gunskins
felines there are quite a few missions
where you think everything would have
worked out even without me and then
there are just a few missions I know
very well would have ended fatally
without my help they're going to happen
time and again you need them for
yourself as a validation after all the
other operations where you think that
would have turned out all right
even if I hadn't come a feeling and an
answer to a meeting there's when Ireland
began
then it's time to go out again there's
been an accident on the Matterhorn
the rescue team has no idea in advance
of what they may be facing but they're
ready for anything they get more details
by radio a mountain climber has fallen
50 meters down the rock face the rescue
team has to winch him out
we're at 4,000 meters and the
temperature is still over 10 degrees
that's unusual
helicopters lose power with warmer
temperatures and it's not long before
you've reached the limit in the early
years before I became a father it was
just an adventure but now it's a
different situation in the back of my
mind I'm thinking I have to return home
again
the pilot seeks a place where he can set
the climber down he's aiming for the
Hurley hooter a mountain cabin at the
foot of the Matterhorn the Mountaineer
is uninjured but still suffering from
shock
always born faster the moment I lost
control
heretic rate up
it's helping stop that stopped us cases
like these are not unusual at the only
hooter every day up to a hundred
climbers set out from here to the
matterhorn cabin manager court labor is
himself a member of the Mountain Rescue
Squad he does what he can to inform the
climbers and warn them about the dangers
and labyrinths it's like a labyrinth
when you get going early in the morning
while it's still dark it's hard to find
the right path and many wander off it
that means they're out there longer and
soon all the small things begin to pile
up like the time factor for instance the
longer you're out on the mountain the
more tired you get the less focused you
become so all these small things can
pile up and the dangers and increase the
system give it a favicon
there's already been one fatality this
season feel affinity I know there are
some cases which get under your skin
there are sometimes these twist of fate
when a climber has fallen to his death
and that's the way it is but his family
comes here and you have to tell them the
news yourself that's always disturbing
safety the next distress call comes in
there's been a fall somewhere north of
the Matterhorn
vaulters colleague Volker lishka takes
on the job it doesn't look good
we don't know who we don't know what's
going on it's a solo climber apparently
there's no group there that we could
talk to he could have had a heart
problem
he could have stumbled it could be
anything at the moment we can only
speculate
ishka looks for witnesses then the
helicopter crews spot a man lying dead
on the mountainside he quite obviously
slid across the snow field and plunged
more than 100 meters
moments like this are hard for the team
even after their years of training
towards failure in deaths in emergency
medicine are just part of life everyone
has a strategy for dealing with it what
I do is discuss it with the team
Valter shift is over for today
but he's still on standby he's ready to
be called out on a mission
24 hours a day seven days a week
you